E.T.: The Extra-Terrestrial is a masterpiece,
and one of the highest-grossing films of all
time.
It's a simple story, an alien gets lost in
a generic suburb, a lonely little boy named
Elliot takes him in, and they establish a
profound psychic and emotional bond.
Elliot and his siblings help E.T. "phone home"
to his planet of origin for a rescue:
"Home.
Phone."
"E.T. phone home.”
...but first they have to make sure E.T. gets
off of Earth without being obliterated by
creepy government agents.
Young E.T. fans who grew up into adults may
notice that the movie is a little… different
than they might remember.
There are all kinds of details, great and
small, that flew right over kids' heads like
they were a mob of alien-protecting tweens
on bikes.
These are the things you only notice in E.T.
as an adult.
No grown-ups allowed!
E.T.: The Extra-Terrestrial is a kids' movie.
This isn't to say that it's a movie for kids,
but more that it is literally a movie full
of kids.
It's a look into Kid World: how kids react
to divorce, how kids have their own secret
suburban societies, how kids conceal and help
a friendly alien visitor, and how kids fight
a bunch of government spooks.
A kid might not be totally aware that it's
a big deal they're seeing themselves up on
that screen, because it reflects their everyday
life, which is kids-only with the occasional
adult interruption.
In fact, for most of the movie, the only adult
face you'll see is that of Elliot's mother.
“Oh My God!"
Despite a lengthy classroom scene, audiences
don't see Elliot's teacher's face, and then
when adults do show up, they're mostly bad
guys.
To enhance the movie's childlike point of
view, Steven Spielberg, the boy wonder of
the movies, shot a lot of the film at a kid's
eye level.
What’s your name?
Audiences learn a lot about Elliot over the
course of E.T.: The Extra-Terrestrial.
He's about 11 years old, loves red-hooded
sweatshirts, lives in the suburbs, has two
siblings, and he can connect telepathically
with an alien.
As for that alien, he has a glowing finger
and a light-up heart, can bring plants back
to life, he likes beer and candy, and is just
trying to get home.
And that's about all we know about Elliot
and E.T.
One thing that becomes clear upon viewing
with jaded, nitpicky, adult eyes: neither
Elliot's last name, nor E.T.'s real name,
are ever given.
“Can you, say E-T?
E.T."
"E.T."
Elliot and all the other kids just call their
magical alien visitor "E.T.," short for "extra-terrestrial".
They can live in each other's minds, but a
simple name exchange never occurs.
Obvious product placement
One of the most endearing scenes in E.T. occurs
when Elliot fully befriends his little alien
roommate by enticing him with a trail of well-placed
Reese's Pieces.
The gentle, telekinetic alien at the heart
of E.T. just can't get enough of those candy-coated
sweetened peanut butter gems.
Yep, to a kid's eye, this seems like a cute
and organic moment.
To a savvy or cynical adult, however, E.T.'s
love of Reese's Pieces is a glaring, less-than-magical
example of Hershey-approved product placement.
It's a wonder E.T. didn't tell Elliott he
needed to "phone home with AT&T."
The candy company’s million-dollar promotional
gambit worked: in the immediate wake of the
film's success, sales of Reese's Pieces tripled.
Even decades later, the advertising blitz
has proven to be profitable.
We believe you can fly
It's one of the most spectacular and satisfying
moments in movie history.
As Elliot, his brother, and his brother's
friends race their bikes to get a weakened
E.T. back to his spaceship, they come across
a roadblock of government agents that want
to take E.T. away and do who knows what to
him.
“Tell me when it’s over!”
It looks like our heroes are sunk…until
E.T. uses his special powers to launch the
whole bicycle contingent up into the sky and
they fly away.
The silhouette of E.T. and Elliot on a bike
is such an iconic image that director Steven
Spielberg used it as the logo for his film
production company, Amblin Entertainment.
It Drew you in
Revisiting beloved childhood movies has more
appeal than just the nostalgia factor.
We want to see if the movies we loved as kids
"hold up."
Are they legitimately good, or did we just
like them because we were dumb kids?
Watching as an adult, you're aware of the
people behind the roles.
For example, only an adult will realize upon
adult-aged viewing that adorable little Gertie
is actually America's Sweetheart, Drew Barrymore,
star of Charlie's Angels and The Wedding Singer.
What's a ‘cintus supremus’?
Some of the insults in E.T. levied by kids
make no sense at all, but only an adult's
ears realize that some of these words have
never been seriously used outside of E.T..
Notably, when Michael's friend Greg calls
Elliot a "cintus supremus."
“Cintus supremus.”
“Zero charisma.”
"Zero charisma!"
"Cintus supremus!"
"Shut up, Greg!"
While the movie’s subtitles spell out this
strange tween put-down, the words don’t
actually mean anything.
Perhaps it's a bit of fake Latin, an enduring
insult-slang phenomenon best embodied by the
old chestnut "dorkus malorkus."
E.T. is kinda terrifying
Kids have fewer preconceived notions than
adults about the world around them, which
makes them often much more accepting and open-hearted
to those that are different.
At least, that's one theme of E.T., the kids
love the little guy straightaway, and most
of the adults want to capture him, run tests
on him, or kill him.
“Hoooome.”
Here's the deal, though: Adults have every
reason to be suspicious and terrified of E.T.
He's a shriveled, waddling mass with huge,
glassy eyes, not to mention he's got a long,
bony light-finger and a glowing, possibly
radioactive heart.
If the average adult came across something
in the woods that looked like an E.T., they
wouldn't give it hugs and Reese's Pieces,
they'd run away screaming.